hi everyone I'm Sam Copeland with
chess.com recently we've launched a
number of new features and updates to
game review and I'm here to tell you all
about them first up report cards unlike
the ones you get in school these are fun
and useful the first thing you'll see is
a summary from your coach describing how
the game went below that you will see a
performance rating for the game an
estimate of your level of play based on
that single game previously we've
received a lot of questions about what
rating your accuracy for a particular
game might equal well this is that
answer
additionally you'll get a quick grade
for each phase of the game based on your
opening middle game and in-game play
grades are displayed as move
classifications ranging from blonder to
brilliant this should help you know
exactly where you need to improve and
for more data check out chess.com
insights or chess.com stats
next up we've made two significant
improvements to classifications we have
introduced a new classification miss a
Miss happens when a player fails to take
advantage of a tactical opportunity such
as finding Checkmate or punishing an
opponent's bad move however a Miss does
not indicate that the move you played
was a bad idea in general for example if
you had an advantage your opponent made
an error allowing a winning combination
and you failed to find the combination
but you did keep your advantage this
would have been considered a mistake or
a blunder but now it will more
accurately be considered a Miss we've
also recalibrated how the blunder
classification Works making it more
meaningful and useful now a blender must
not only drop the positions evaluation
significantly it must also lose material
or allow Checkmate we think this is how
most expert chess coaches would describe
a blunder it is not about some loss of
eval according to a computer it is about
creating a tangible exploitable
opportunity for the opponent a mostly
behind the scenes Improvement is that we
have completely overhauled our book
database it should now better match
well-known opening Theory we've added
known opening moves to the book
classification and we are removing book
modes that are simply bad moves we've
also recognized that sometimes coaches
feedback can be hard to follow you can
now have Coach draw arrows and highlight
squares over the board to help you
understand the advice you can do this by
hovering over or clicking on the
highlighted words in coach's explanation
of a particular move with this you can
much more easily visualize the pieces
tactics and ideas that coach refers to
and last but certainly not least we've
given coach more in-depth move
explanations coach now helps you to see
all of the threats behind each move and
whether those threats are prevented or
allowed the coach will also mention
specific pieces so you'll know if coach
is talking about a night Bishop Rook or
any other piece we are constantly
working to improve coach's explanations
so if you haven't taken a close look at
the explanations lately give them
another try and let us know what you
think the new game review experience is
available on chess.com right now and
look for all of these features to make
their way into the apps later this year
foreign